The last point I want to touch on with the Dimple library.
And usually this is possible with any library built on D3,
is how we can interact with the dimple-created charts with native JavaScript,
CSS or D3 code to add additional customizations.
Here we can see the chart that we created as a combination of a dimple
scatter and a dimple line.
But one improvement that I wanted to add is to
color the scatter circles red to draw more attention to them or
we can do this through dimple code D3 code or Java Script code.
The simplest way to make this slight change is to use CSS.
When customizing a chart created by another higher level library,
we often need to find some class or ID to select the elements.
In this case the circles.
If we inspect element and look at the SVG created by dimple we can see here that
its a circle element with the ID equal to the date.
And going over further,
we can see that there's a bunch of different classes added to it.
Since, we want to make all the circles red, the ID won't work.
So we have to pick one of the classes, or
a few of them to change the styling on all the circles.
In this case, it looks like all the circles are dimple series-1 class.
Which is probably a good guess for
a class attached to all of the circles and none of the lines.
Which we can then use in a CSS selector.
In our HTML file we simply need to add a CSS style to the page as a whole.
That selects circles with dimple series-1 class.
Here we are selecting the circle elements with dimple series-1.
And we're changing the fill property of the SVG circle to be red.
Saving our file and reloading our page.
And you can see here that the fill of the circles is now red,
which makes them a little bit more distinguishable.